No mamma io non ce la faccio a partorirò
Oh ma cosa mi è venuto in mente ma io
quando volevo diventare mamma mica
l'avevo capito che poi dovevo partorire
epidurale ma per forza mii per forza se
non muoio praticamente tempo di alzarmi
faccio colazione 2 minuti e già sono
stanca che metto a dormire quando mi
sveglio È ora di pranzo mangio e vado a
dormire mi addormento sul divano davanti
alla TV Dopodiché mi sveglio che l'ora
di cena cena è già mentre sto finendo di
cenare Mmm mi sento di nuovo stanca e
allora vado a letto e niente Sono
quattro mesi che non faccio altro che
dormire in continuazione e ti dicono di
non mangiare cose crude di non bere di
non fumare di non respirare ma se mia
nonna quando era incinta di mia mamma
pescare i pesci dal fiume li mangiava
con le spine e mamma è nata sana come un
pesce sono tutte riaccende metropolitane
ma l'importante è divertirsela
serenamente capito senza toglierti i
piaceri della vita io queste mamme che
quando rimangono incinte smetterò di
allenarsi proprio non le capisco Ma
scusami è il momento più importante per
allenarsi perché sì perché il bambino
una volta che qui dentro assorbe tutto
Certo io adesso forse di fare zumba lo
sento Eh lo sento che si muove che
shaker che twerk tanto è appena nasce
lui inizierà a fare danza propedeutica
per neonati è certo Condividilo hai
preso tu solo 18 ma io 24 sono solo al
terzo mese Oh Però posso dirti comunque
Ali sbadiamo poi e poi non è che siamo
noi che abbiamo fame è bambino Capito
deve crescere quindi ha fame lui quindi
noi mangiamo lui in realtà quindi una
volta che lui esce spariscono
tesoro c'è bisogno chiedi pure Eh sì Sì
ormai sono un'esperta causa in questi
cinque mesi ho letto una quantità di
libri credo all'incirca 345 libri Sì sì
so tutto ormai sul parto sul rapporto
madre bimbo su come affrontare la
gravidanza Sul rapporto papà bimbo
adesso come vestirvi vestirli cambiare
le pannolini farli crescere fare
diventare De Vincenti Calcola che
suonando lezioni private Le mie spese
che la mia ginecologa per forza son
troppo brava No ma ti giuro mi scappa la
pipì in continuazione proprio una
tortura esco di casa mi scappa la pipì
vado al supermercato mi scappa la pipì
salgo sulla macchina Mi scappa la pipì
Addirittura mi scappa la pipì dopo aver
fatto la pipì No ma io pensavo che coi
primi mesi poi finissero le nausee Ma è
un vomito in continuazione guarda basta
niente che proprio tipo adesso no scusa
un attimo Uhm Oh amo preparo il mio
lavoro per sapere l'ospedale Ah ho
capito che sono del terzo mese quindi il
tempo vola Quanti sono 7 a 9